fermé pour une durée indéterminée cette
décision radicale a été prise le 8
janvier dernier par les salariés
eux-mêmes à cause des nombreux actes
d'incivilité alerté le groupe lagardère
dont dépend de ses enseignes a émis
quelques mesures recrutement d'un vigile
réduction des amplitudes horaires et des
places assises installation de caméras
de vidéosurveillance insuffisant pour
trois des six salariés le rideau reste
donc baisser les clients comprennent
j'ai eu des amis qui ont été victimes
d'harcèlement par des mains des jeunes
monsieur bourg et qu'on passe dans le
souterrain c'est vrai qu' on est souvent
on est soit interpellé puis c'est vrai
que l'on n'ose pas s'aventurer tout seul
le soir dans le souterrain vols
dégradations trafics en tous genres les
actes de malveillance dont et autour de
la gare se seraient multipliées ces
derniers mois
pour ce syndicaliste d'alliance c'est à
cause de la baisse des effectifs
oui on manque d'effectifs comme partout
en france si vous avez dit
fonctionnaires en plus c'est autant de
patrouille que vous pouvez mobilisés par
la santé parce qu'ils seront pas tous là
ce moment là mais enfin vous pouvez
renforcer les services et ça permet une
attitude aussi à la hiérarchie de
constituer des effectifs en patrouille
qui pourront aller plus facilement la
guerre parce qu'il n'ya pas que la gare
algérie faux problème rétorque le
commissaire divisionnaire par contre qui
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'actuellement la
gare de belfort attirer des gens qui
d'habitude sont peuvent être ailleurs
dans la rue ou dans certains halls
d'immeubles pourquoi parce qu'en ce
moment il fait froid et que la gare
étant un lieu chauffé la gare en ce
moment à tyr autre chose que des
voyageurs ce qui peut créer peut-être un
certain climat d'insécurité
aucune plainte ni ma courante n'aurait
été déposée
une réunion doit se tenir dans les
prochains jours entre la préfecture la
sncf la police nationale et municipale